je voudrais qu'on se parle de tesla
aujourd'hui voudrais vous donner des
secrets tout savoir sur tesla des choses
que vous ne savez pas nécessairement de
choses que vous saurez peut-être
d'ailleurs dit que le mois en
commentaire et puis si vous connaissez
des choses si vous avez des précisions
des choses que vous savez vous pouvez
également les marques et en commentaire
comme ça ça agrémentent le débat et
c'est intéressant pour tout le monde
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour des
choses méconnues sur tesla c'est parti
c'est un format de vidéo je vous ai fait
j'ai déjà fait les secrets de samsung
les secrets de xiaomi aujourd'hui on se
parle d'automobiles on se parle de tesla
tesla qui une marque d'automobile mais
une marque tech avant tout pour qu a
plein de choses à voir à voir la
première chose mes notes sont l'un donc
si j'ai les yeux qui porte en bas vous
inquiétez pas j'ai beau tout appris par
coeur et j'ai pas de prompteur dont je
lis tesla a été fondée en 2003 par qui
n'ont pas par elon musk qui aujourd'hui
dirige la boîte il est arrivé un petit
peu après on va le voir dans quelques
instants a été fondée par martin o
martin martin et burn hockey et marc
tarling voilà j'essaye de faire le nom
avec un peu d'accent c'est un peu
poussif alors le but de tesla c'était
quoi c'est un but qui beaucoup plus
large col automobile tesla ça fait
référence à l'automobile pour tout le
monde m'en foutais là c'est beaucoup
plus le but de tesla c'est d'accélérer
la transition mondiale vers un schéma
énergétique durable autant vous dire
qu'avec sa tesla peuvent faire tout et
n'importe quoi tant que c'est dans
l'énergie durable alors il commence par
une automobile au début s'appelait tesla
motors bien mais ils ont changé non un
peu plus tard c'était en 2017 pour
devenir tesla incorporated passez la
brosse et tesla que vous connaissez ça
veut donc dire que c'est beaucoup plus
large et que tesla va pouvoir avoir
plusieurs ramifications de l'automobile
mais pas que il s'en va le voir un peu
plus loin dans la vidéo d'ailleurs petit
aparté penser à venir vous abonner pour
venir regarder toutes ces vidéos de
secret de test des actus tech et c'est
que je vais venir vous donner
régulièrement donc le petit bouton et là
il est rouge si les rouges c'est que
vous n'êtes pas abonné puis pensez à
venir actionner la cloche même si vous
êtes déjà abonné pour être notifiées et
tout savoir dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera alors il arrivait quand ce
bourbier yellen muscles j'ai dit le mot
ridicule il est arrivé qu'en ce beau
veille elon musk il est arrivé en 2004
il est arrivé juste après alors elon
musk si vous savez c'est monsieur k
fournée paypal alors aujourd'hui on
connaît space x qu'on était ce là mais
on oublie rapidement paypal par derrière
il a un peu d'oseille quand ils arrivent
le lendemain ce cas il investit il
apporte 6,5 millions de dollars sur les
7,5 millions qui sont levés en février
2004 autant vous dire que il arrive
c'est lui qui prend plus d'action et
c'est lui qui pèse le plus lourd dans la
boîte parce qu'il arrive en tant
qu'investisseur alors il rejoint la
boîte et après il devient président du
conseil d'administration
alors vous allez voir il va se passer
des choses mais ça on voit un peu après
au début tu es seul à travailler sur une
voiture haut de gamme n'ont pas commencé
par des modèles retour des modèles très
très haut de gamme en effet tu as la
maison pas commencer par des véhicules
ayant vocation à être démocratisée et du
grand public il fallait se faire
connaître il fallait commencer par des
produits un peu différent ils ont
commencé par la tesla roadster alors la
tesla roadster c'est l'autonomie de 370
kilomètres a pris 2,84 mille euros c'est
quand même pas rien et qui fait son 0 à
100 en 3,9 secondes quand vous dire que
déjà à l'époque s'envoyer un max de
sensations avec une pointe jusqu'à 220
km est ce qu'on ne sait pas
nécessairement c'est que cette tesla
roadster elle a été conçue avec le
soutien de lotus cars soit c'est
probablement lotus ont des voitures très
haut de gamme ils sont venus aider tesla
là dessus parce que le châssis de la
tesla roadster c'est celle de la lotus
elise ayant un taux qui est vachement
intéressant c'est que la carrosserie à
carrosserie en fibre de carbone a été
fabriqué en france ouais cocorico elle a
été fabriquée en ille et vilaine à saint
méloir des ondes mais vous m'en direz
des nouvelles et d'ailleurs ce tesla
roadster il a été envoyé dans l'espace
c'est la première voiture qui a été
envoyé dans l'espace qui était lancée en
2018 bord de space x et qui toujours en
orbite autour du soleil qui se situe
quelque part entre la terre et mars il
ya un côté un peu mégalo derrière mais
faut reconnaître que c'est aussi un peu
funky alors il ya d'autres personnes qui
sont arrivées dans tesla parce qu'on
connaît beaucoup au lendemain il n'y a
pas que lui qui arrive et qui investit
on a vu également arrivé en tant
qu'investisseurs et bien les
cofondateurs de google rien que sergei
green et lounge tout fait l'accent et
puis l'ancien président div et qui
s'appelle jeff collias alors après il se
passe des choses un peu pas folle chez
tesla ça se secoue ça se bouge un peu au
niveau des co fondateurs que sont martin
eberhard et mark canning en fait en août
2007 cas le conseil d'administration qui
demande à amber heard de quitter son
poste de président directeur général on
sent qu'il est légèrement poussé vers la
sortie il se retrouve président de la
technologie puis il finit globalement à
partir oui parce que je te clair qu'à un
moment quand on passe de pdg à un autre
poste même s'il est très bien on sent
qu'on veut vous pousser dehors et que ça
va pas le faire longtemps et puis très
peu de temps après il ya marc tapping
qui l'a suivi qui était jusque là vice
président de l'ingénierie électrique est
parti en janvier 2008 alors il ya eu un
autre pdg qui arrive entre temps puis au
final très rapidement en octobre 2008
ces lots de masques qui est devenu
président directeur général de tesla y
qu'il est d'ailleurs toujours
aujourd'hui alors quand on pense à tesla
on pense à quoi on pense à des voitures
électriques mais on pense surtout à
l'auto pilotes et à la conduite autonome
alors même s'il ya une réglementation
qui différentes entre les etats-unis et
la france où nous de toujours garder les
mains sur le volant aux us on peut lui
éléments et puis sur autoroute ça roule
tout seul il a un côté très pratique
mais c'est vraiment cette ode aux
pilotes qui arrivait lui 2014 et à
partir selon là les voitures ont été
livrés avec des capteurs pour permettre
justement cette aide à la conduite rien
d'autre truc on sait pas forcément je
vous disais au début c'était cela motors
qui a changé de nom qu'ils vont du tesla
et ils veulent aller vers un schéma
d'énergie durable et c'est dans ce sens
là qu'ils ont racheté en 2016 solarcity
solarcity c'est une boîte qui a été
créée par les cousins des lônes bastion
2006 et eux ils ont racheté en 2016
solarcity sont spécialisées dans les
énergies solaires photovoltaïques et
qu'est ce qui se passe solar cities
change de nom se rapprochent déjà de
tesla et devient tesla energy et avança
déjà il faut savoir que sur leur site il
est très proche de tesla ils fournissent
et une recharge gratuite à tous les
possesseurs du tesla roadster alors
tesla il ya aussi un côté
philanthropique c'est très américain
sein la philanthropie qui l'ont fait pas
mal de choses et c'est plutôt bien en
2017 en 2017 ils sont venus en aide à un
hôpital de porto rico en installant un
système de production photovoltaïque et
de stockage pour internet rétablir
l'électricité après une catastrophe
alors attendez ça s'arrête pas là pour
2018 ils ont fait don de 37,5 millions
de dollars à système d'éducation dans le
nevada et en 2020 ils ont donné 5
millions de wons soit à peu près 7 123
mille dollars au centre chinois de
contrôle et de prévention pour lutter
contre le coc vide 19 alors y'a des
trucs aussi intéressant du côté du
bitcoin sais pas si vous avez suivi
c'était en 2021 c'est assez récente et
cela a investi près de 1,5 milliard de
dollars dans le bitcoin et ils ont
annoncé qu'ils accepteraient le bitcoin
comme moyen de paiement pour l'heure
tesla ok sauf que très peu de temps
après ils ont fait un rétropédalage
est-ce qu'ils sont fait taper dessus on
ne saura pas toujours est il qu'ils ont
dit ok on n'accepte plus le bitcoin à
cause des préoccupations climatiques
parce que le minage pour aux mines et du
bitcoin est bien c'est assez énergivores
c'est pas bon pour la planète ya des
endroits où on va miner ou à des usines
de charbon derrière c'est pas bon du
tout ils ont dit ok non le bitcoin c'est
bien mais n'ont pour l'instant donné ils
ont dit quand ça sera un peu plus green
on verra oui probablement pas tout de
suite mon hockey alors on s'en doutera
avec tous ces véhicules que sortait cela
et toutes ces solutions et commence un
peu à gagner d'argent après des années d
années d année à perdre de l'argent ils
ont comment s'organise c'était en 2020
et on voit qu'il ya un profit en 2021
c'est assez récent un profit de 5,5
milliards de dollars avec une marge
opérationnelle de 12% ce pas dégueu il
ya une partie de leur chiffre d'affaires
qui est générée par des services des
services d'abonnement vous savez comme
lorsque vous à venir payer des trucs en
plus parce qu'il ya le coût de votre
voiture et après il ya tout ce qu'on
peut acheter en plus rares donc ils
sentent une option vous l'a trouvée
intéressante vous voulez acheter
maintient intactes pour ajouter deux
mille 4000 euros pour à votre option en
plus et puis vous avez des services
d'abonnement et notamment le fait d'
activer le wifi dans la voiture fait
bref voilà donc la voie il ya beaucoup
d'options et avec ça ils ont rayé
deuxième trimestre 2000 20 500 millions
de dollars deuxième trimestre 2010 au
canada alors je vais vous parler des
ventes mondiales d'automobiles du côté
de tesla retourne à 2021 en fait ils ont
été proche du million d'exemplaires
vendus en 2021 c'est quand même pas mal
aurait une progression de 87 % par
rapport à 2020 il faut aussi savoir que
2020 et lyon c'était l'année de début de
la crise lui convient donc forcément le
marché automobile s'était pas aimé la
maman pour lui et ils ont quand même
livré 936
1177 véhicules dont 911 1208 modèle 3 et
y confondues et 26
1964 modèle x y model s tesla c'est
également un procès un procès sais pas
si vous le savez la marque tesla avait
déjà été déposée en chine et cristal
peut pas venir exploiter cette marque en
chine ya donc eu un procès est un moment
ils se sont dit on va venir
commercialiser nos véhicules sous la
marque free au soler je ne parlent pas
chinois je prononcerai maltais huot sql
eux mais au bout du bout ça s'est pas
fait parce que en 2014 ils ont eu gain
de cause et ils ont pu avoir la marque
tesla et l'utiliser en chine donc voilà
plutôt pas mal voilà la vérité il est
quand même pas mal de petites choses
qu'on savait pas nécessairement je sais
pas si vous connaissez ces différents
points que j'étais fouiner à droite à
gauche regarder pour vous trouvez ça est
ce que ça vous intéresse est ce que vous
avez appris des choses sur tesla est ce
que vous aimez la marque tesla est est
ce que vous avez un véhicule électrique
et est ce que tu es cela pourrait vous
plaire d'ailleurs et est ce que ça vous
intéresse ça que je teste des tesla
voulu marquer en bas en commentaire et
si vous connaissez d'autres chaussures
c'est cela vous y allez quand les
commentaires on aura vu ça c'est cool
d'ici là prenez soin de vous embrasser
si vous voulez d'autres vidéos comme ça
bien vous me le dites aussi dans les
commentaires sont là pour ça et bisous
pour des soins et beaucoup beaucoup de
notables
[Musique]